I have an update on the whole YouTube
account suspension ordeal long story
short it's getting fixed which is good
news I want to give a huge thank you to
my moderation team for helping to
coordinate information from you guys in
the community who have been affected by
it to the people at YouTube who have
been in contact which is also very good
to getting information to me and
collecting all this so I can bring it to
you guys but long story short it is
getting fixed now that does leave a few
other questions out of the loop like how
did this happen why did this happen and
will it happen again in the future which
I'm hoping to hit all of these points in
the time that we are going to have in
the future so I have to start this off
with a story I got a call from Susanne
Daniels
Susanne Daniels is the head of content
at YouTube Susanne Daniels is the person
that greenlit a heist with markiplier
Susanne Daniels is calling me and I was
like this is it all right my show is
getting canceled I'm gonna have to
delete my channel here I go well hello
but no Susanne Daniels was I don't know
why I keep saying her full name
Susanne was very lovely Susanne
expressed a lot of genuine concern that
this happened in the first place she was
very worried about it she was very
worried that this could happen and she
was adamant in saying that she would do
everything in her power to make sure
that this never happens again
which is really good to hear especially
from someone so high up in YouTube and
it didn't sound like just PR speak
because she also gave me her personal
contact information and told me that if
something like this ever happens again
to contact her directly which meant a
lot to me and it also speaks to the
point that not everyone at YouTube is a
mindless soulless corporate drone there
are a lot of people at YouTube who
genuinely care about the platform as
they should I genuinely care about the
platform and that's why I made the video
in the first place and there are lots of
people that we're working through the
weekend to fix this problem and it
speaks to the point where obviously
myself included can get very heated
about these things I was personally
upset because I've been through this
before but it is good to hear that
people
or listening I would like to think that
the majority of the people that work at
YouTube do genuinely care about their
users and I believe that I really do
believe that there are probably some
that don't like there's some that don't
in every circumstance that you find
yourself in but I do believe that the
majority do want what's best for the
people that use their platform and it's
good to hear that they agree that this
was definitely not in accordance with
what was best for the people who use
YouTube now I'm getting out of the story
and getting into the more nitty-gritty
of the details I want to turn to this
particular reddit post by someone who
works as a software engineer at YouTube
and they're part of the community
engagement team which is why they're
posting on reddit number one the
accounts have been reinstated I can
confirm this I cannot confirm that all
of the accounts have been reinstated but
as far as we the mod team and myself are
concerned the majority of the people
that have been affected have gotten
their accounts back there are still some
problems with some people missing
YouTube videos in their YouTube accounts
so if you've been affected by this
please check your YouTube account to
make sure your videos are still there
this I've been told is a fixable problem
so don't panic they will return a get in
contact with YouTube through Twitter or
reach out to my mod team or email
YouTube to make sure that they are aware
that you are experiencing that problem
one of the big issues is that this
happened over the weekend and a lot of
YouTube's team doesn't work weekends
especially the people that make the code
that changes things on YouTube this is
still an ongoing fix but they are aware
of it and they know that they can fix it
which is what really matters
number two is an explanation of what
happened it was an anti-spam measure
which is what I suspected which is what
a lot of us suspected and what we were
pretty sure happened anyway there's a
lot of spam on YouTube there's a lot of
spam on anything that live streams so
this was one of those algorithms going
rogue and going way way way too far
this person mentioned something about
having to confirm with an SMS code but
obviously that's
not what happened I'm gonna jump over
0.3 I'm gonna get back to point three
but this ties into point four this is
what should happen because people were
appealing it and people were confirming
it and this is where I really appreciate
this I really do honestly appreciate
they are saying outright the appeals
should not have been denied
we definitely [ __ ] up their quote
unquote that means a lot to be it means
something to me that they admit that
they [ __ ] up and that's honestly it's
good to hear it's not good that it
happened no not by any stretch of the
imagination it's not good that they
happened but it's good that they said it
because they did and obviously they did
and that was the thing that angered me
the most as I said in my other video
that was the one thing that angered me
more than anything else was people
getting denied without people checking
now going back to point three he says
that the emote spam in question was not
minor the accounts affected averaged
well over a hundred messages each within
a short timeframe
I don't know what their timeframe is but
a hundred messages even in a minute is
something that I can achieve in my spam
fingers of mine but I could understand
how that would be flagged I get that I
still think it's normal behavior but it
can seem abnormal especially when I'm
calling for people to vote using emotes
they would probably copy-paste multiple
times now that being said it's still a
mistake but I hope this can alleviate a
lot of concerns that it's one line of
emotes could possibly get your account
banned because that apparently is not
the case it is people that I bet were
copy-pasting not saying that they are
and the wrong in any way shape or form
this should never happen just because of
that but I can see where that came about
and that ties in to number four where
the people who were approving it would
casually look at this they look at the
numbers being like okay a hundred
messages in 90 seconds oh that
definitely seems like spam like no like
definitely confirm that I can see how it
happened
I'm not forgiving it in any way shape or
form absolutely not but it's important
to understand the context of how things
happen so you get the hyperbole out of
it you get the oh they're just villains
over there at the the appeal process
there they're just monsters that are
looking for any excuse to ban an account
because it nine times out of ten it's
not actually someone with malicious
intent it's a mistake
and in a company the size of YouTube and
this is in point five in a company the
size of YouTube it can seem like YouTube
doesn't care they've got a lot of [ __ ]
to deal with
and I've always recognized that fact
even my channel for how big it is with
twenty four million subscribers is a
drop in the bucket compared to YouTube
as a whole but that's also why it means
a lot when something as simple as them
saying yeah we [ __ ] up that means a
lot to me that really does Susanne
Daniels reaching out to me personally
that means a lot it really does my
contact at YouTube Meg working on her
day off to try to get me in touch with
the YouTube operations team even before
I made the video working on her vacation
trying to make sure that this problem
got solved that means a lot to be my
moderators going out of their way to
collect data from people that were
affected and make sure that it all is in
a nice even list that means a lot it
really does mean a lot and it gives me
hope like I am still mad that this
happened in the first place and I am so
sorry to the people that it was
affecting out there and I am still gonna
stay on youtubes ask to make sure that
they follow through and change their
systems so that this doesn't happen
again which seems to be the general
course of action that they are on the
path of but at the same time this is
about the best hope I could have had for
the resolution of this problem this is
like this is about the brightest silver
lining that I could have possibly seen
happening out of this I was so ready to
be like well alright they're gonna come
for me if I disappear
you know you might want to suspect
YouTube that maybe there was foul play
like like but hey you know this is
pretty cool any and it there there's so
many other things that my my moderators
collected here there's a lot of people
that have managed to get their accounts
back my account is back whoo I've been
freed good news all my videos are not
lost which is good so that means that it
is being fixed if the videos are gone
check my account I still my gold heart
so members who have still maintained
their progress they haven't lost their
progress this is good news it's really
good
like I'm I'm so goddamn grateful of you
guys for rallying behind this because it
was an important thing to get their
attention I I don't want to make videos
that are call-out posts i I don't revel
in drama but this was important and it's
the best outcome I could possibly hope
for they're still working on it
obviously it is not completely done it's
not gonna be completely done for
probably a few more days but like you
know they listened I gotta give it a
little props for that I mean it
shouldn't happen at the first play
that's for sure
but they listened it's a long story
short the problem is getting fixed it
still needs probably a few more days to
work out all the kinks but people should
be getting their accounts back the the
spam system should be working again
people should be able to trust live
streams and they should know that if
this does happen again you can reach out
to people in this community and they
will actually care I think that's the
coolest thing of all so with that I will
wrap it up thank you everybody so much
for watching I will give you guys an
update if there's anything else that
needs to be known but keep reaching out
to my mods if you have any further
problems keep reaching out to youtube if
you have any further problems and I will
keep on them to make sure that they
follow up with what they have told me so
thank you everybody and as always I'll
see you in the next one bye bye